[La musique]
Je ne pense pas que ce soit bon, je pense que tout le monde
les gens devraient pouvoir décider par eux-mêmes
qu'il soit vacciné ou non
Je pense qu'il y a d'autres issues
attacher plus pas toujours particulièrement
eh bien ça n'oblige certainement pas les gens
oui c'est dommage d'en arriver là
venir que trop de gens pas quelque part
que vous devez les forcer à le faire parce qu'il
devrait en fait aller de soi
sois ainsi pour toi-même pour les autres
parle de vaccination obligatoire et
pas de vaccination obligatoire et c'est celle-là pour moi
sérieuse différence tout le monde peut
décider volontairement s'il, pour ainsi dire
la restitution accepte alors
ne va plus à la gastronomie ou
Je ne peux pas voyager, je pense
que peu de ceux qui, jusqu'à aujourd'hui, n'ont pas
être vacciné sous la contrainte fédérale
se faire vacciner l'autre l'autre
qui sont strictement contre
médical idéologique politique
la raison égalisera encore
[La musique]